but with unravelled you met Yanni a tiny
little character with a huge heart going
on an epic adventure you also met Martin
Celine a passionate and creative game
maker from the cold world studio that
brought Yanni to life
we knew unravel would steal your hearts
because it stole ours but it also showed
us something profound when we first saw
unravel we saw a game that we knew
deserve the world's attention it
deserved to be played we also know that
there are more out there more Studios
like cold with more games like unravel
passionate developers telling amazing
stories creating spectacular games we
are committed to working with small
developers finding these great new games
and giving all of you a chance to
discover their magic so today we are
very excited to announce EA originals
our original program is about three
things firstly it's about taking
first-time experiences that are unique
gorgeous innovative and memorable and
bringing them to the world secondly it's
about supporting small developers and
helping them make the most of their
games now we'll seek out a few projects
each year for originals and partnered
with them through the whole process from
development to marketing to publishing
and lastly it's about funding and
offering a level of security now making
games is hard it's a hard business and
these small developers have risked
themselves to develop a new IP and
created games deserved at great games
deserve to be played now check this out
with ETA originals we want all the
profit from these games to go back into
the hands of the developers so they can
keep innovating and creating into the
future
now we've already begun with the
originals so please welcome to our stage
Klaus Linga led from joint games in
Gothenburg he is here to take you into
the beautiful world of our first EA
originals game called fear
hi everyone
wow it's amazing to be here joining you
all a TA play here in Los Angeles it's
well it's really huge for me and I'm
super excited to be here I run a small
game studio in Sweden in Gothenburg
coats oink and we're about 20 people
brought together by our fascination for
new approaches to interactive
storytelling and art and recently we've
been on a journey with a very special
new project thanks to Patrick and ei
we're here today to bring you along with
us let me introduce you to the world of
C at its heart fame is a personal
narrative about our relationship with
nature
it's a game without words a celebration
of our longing to be one with the world
around us it's a story that reminds us
that everything in this world is
connected living in a delicate balance
that is constantly under threat you
awaken as a young cub all alone in a
dark forest glade and you have no idea
of who you are or how you got there but
as you spy from the treetops you'll soon
come to know the extraordinary creatures
that live in this forest and you'll find
that they're all connected through their
own language a language of strange and
beautiful music see every animal every
breathing creature and even the plants
they all have their own unique song and
by learning them you can connect to the
forest to understand it to be part of it
each song you learn will help you reach
new parts of the forest and take your
ever closer to discovering the secret of
your own kind
but you're not the only new coming to
the forest the silent ones corrupt the
forest and spread their silence with
each step as you of a them using stealth
and cunning you will uncover the
terrible purpose this is a game full of
discovery conflict and relationships but
as you explore the world of faith we're
not going to hold your hand the game
won't tell you where to go what to do or
how to think we will set the stage and
invite you into the forest for your own
personal experience an experience that
will leave you scared amazed and
delighted in the forest your discoveries
will be your own I'm very proud to know
show you more about the beautiful world
of see thank you
you